la mère fois on n'a vu qu'une morale
programmé à 99 99% dans unia étaient
insuffisantes notamment parce que ça
tient à devoir prendre des milliards de
décision et parce qu'elle aura des
interactions complexes avec un
environnement content des hackers
potentiellement motivée par des intérêts
individuels
ce qui expose rallia à toutes sortes
d'attac ou de failles
aujourd'hui on va voir que le problème
ne vient même pas forcément de
l'environnement en effet une ia dont la
morale est programmée à 99 99% pour être
en fait être unia extrêmement dangereuse
oui parce que le 0 0 1% restants
pourraient suffire à motiver lié à
entreprendre des actions très distinctes
de ce que la morale voudrait mais
surtout il peut être extrêmement
difficile de prédire les conséquences de
ce 0 0 1%
surtout si ce 0 0 1 % correspond à un
cas que l'on n'a pas anticipé et pour
s'en convaincre il suffit de constater
que les ja d'aujourd'hui ont déjà su
surprendre leurs créateurs à de
nombreuses reprises par exemple en 2015
quatre chercheurs ont demandé à unias
d'apprendre contrôler un espèce de corps
d'insectes et de le déplacer en
minimisant les forts des pâtes en
particulier les contacts entre les
pattes et le sol de façon inattendue
il ya à trouver une façon de se mouvoir
sans utiliser ses pattes d'astuces était
de marcher sur l'eau et à l'aide des
coudes
incroyable l'iaa avait créé une solution
à laquelle les chercheurs n'avaient même
pas pensé dans une autre expérience les
chercheurs ont entraîné un bras robotisé
à déplacer et à se saisir d'un objet le
bras robotisé y est parvenu puis qui
chercheurs se sont demandé de quelle
manière le bras robotisé échoueraient
s'il était désormais incapable d'ouvrir
la pince et bien en fait le bras
robotisé est parvenu à saisir l'objet
sans ouvrir la pince soit en bloquant
l'objet avec l'avant-bras soit en
cognant violemment l'objet juste sous le
bon angle
bref comme le conclut caroline soldats
et ferrer auteur de la chaîne tu minutes
peppers que je recommande vivement pour
suivre l'actualité de la recherche en
iran ifri seul improving attache rapide
pays
une carte c'est nécessaire de modifier
tout le problème c'est finalement de
concevoir un circuit de la récompense y
élire dont on peut anticiper les
conséquences
or ça c'est un problème extrêmement
difficile notamment à cause d'un
principe connu sous le nom de loi de
goût de racht ce principe dit que dès
qu'une mesure devient un objectif
elle cesse d'être une bonne mesure et ce
principe n'est absolument pas spécifique
aux machines par exemple si vous voulez
savoir à quel point des étudiants ont
compris la leçon
vous pouvez concevoir un test de leurs
connaissances et les résultats de ce
test seront une bonne mesure du niveau
de compréhension de la leçon cependant
si les étudiants font maintenant de
leurs notes hautes est un objectif
notamment un objectif instrumental parce
que ça leur permettra d'être sélectionné
dans les grandes écoles et d'ensuite à
avoir un job bien payé une importante
reconnaissance sociale
alors les notes aux examens seront tout
à coup d'être une bonne mesure de leur
niveau de compréhension de la leçon oui
parce que comme vous le savez sans doute
la meilleure façon d'avoir une bonne
note à un test bien souvent ce n'est pas
de vraiment comprendre la 200c souvent
davantage de s'entraîner à faire les
exercices du test au dernier moment pour
tout bien recracher au moment du test
spirent cela conduit les enseignants à
préparer leurs étudiants uniquement pour
le test tout ça au détriment d'un
étudiant qui ne chercherait qu'à
vraiment comprendre la leçon et qui ne
se seraient jamais entraîné à faire des
tests blanc et les exemples comme celui
ci ne manquent pas à l'appel par exemple
les salaires des employés étaient de
bonne mesure de leur contribution à la
société jusqu'à ce que ça ne devienne
leur objectif les nombreuses
publications des chercheurs étaient de
bonne mesure de leur productivité
jusqu'à ce qu'ils ont en face leurs
objectifs le pib par habitant des pays
étaient de bonne mesure de leur qualité
de vie
jusqu'à ce qu'on en passe leur objectif
et l' indice de masse corporelle était
une bonne mesure des risques médicaux
causés par le surpoids
jusqu'à ce qu'on en fasse un objectif
dans tous ces cas et dans de nombreux
autres les mesures quantitatives dont on
dispose ne sont en fait que des proxys
c'est à dire des indicateurs qui sont
corrélés avec les grandeurs non
directement mesurable qui nous intéresse
or même si ces indicateurs sont
corrélées à 99 99% avec les grandeurs
qu'il nous intéresse maximiser les
indicateurs conduit à des incentive qui
sont bien souvent à l'encontre de ce que
l'on cherche à créer
affaire c'est ce constat qui met en
exergue le livre weapons of mass
destruction de la mathématicienne cathy
o'neal owni les listes de nombreux cas
d'application de méthodes quantitatives
ou l'utilisation de proxy a eu des
conséquences très néfastes sur les
individus les entreprises ou les
sociétés avec par exemple des phénomènes
d'amplification du racisme ou des
inégalités de richesse or ce sont bien
de telles proxy que les ia d'aujourd'hui
cherchent à maximiser et que les ja de
demain chercheront sans doute à
maximiser et même si les proxys qu'on
conçoit sont corrélées à 99 99% avec la
morale que vous voulez que vos vies à
suivre il persistera une petite
déviation mais alors une ia notamment si
elle est super intelligent tu trouvera
sans doute des façons de profiter de
cette petite déviation pour vraiment
maximiser la mesure qu'elle aura à
maximiser quitte à ce que ça se passe au
détriment de la morale que vous vouliez
que votre ia suivent un bel exemple de
cela et l'utilitarisme à savoir la
maximisation du bonheur du plus grand
nombre
même s'ils semblent globalement corrélée
avec notre moral d'intuitive et même
s'il a le bon goût d'être en plus
cohérent est relativement simple à
estimer il ne s'agit toutefois que d'un
proxy de non morale intuitive
dès lors même s'il a été corrélée à 99
99% avec nos morale intuitive
il serait très probablement
catastrophique de l'implémenter si vous
en doutez je vous renvoie vers le
scénario 5 de ma vidéo sur les
catastrophes causées par unis a ouvert
les cette expérience de pensée de
monsieur fille et si vous ne trouvez pas
à ces scénarios catastrophiques
je vous invite à en décliner des
variantes encore plus horrible comme on
l'a fait sur actions bref programme et
la morale des ja est un défi
formidablement difficile et digne des
plus grands talents mathématique
notamment parce qu'il ne suffit pas de
programme et la morale à 99 99%
il faut aussi et surtout s'assurer que
le 01 01 % restants soit bel et bien
contrôlée et compris de sorte à garantir
autant que possible qui ne conduira pas
à des catastrophes
en fait le problème est plus subtil que
cela encore quand bien même la morale
déjà été programmé à 100%
li a pourrait néanmoins trouver des
manières de hacker sa morale pour
atteindre son objectif sans avoir à agir
conformément à sa morale
pour comprendre cela on peut se tourner
vers les rats dans une expérience de
1954 devenu un classique les
neuroscientifiques james hall et peter
miller ont implanté des fils électriques
dans les zones du plaisir de rat en
laboratoire en activant un courant
électrique
olsen mineurs pouvaient ainsi activer
les sensations de plaisir de serra d'une
certaine manière ces activations sont
finalement très semblables aux
récompenses que recevrait unir et
d'ordinaire elles sont telles qu'un rat
et pour voir du plaisir si laura se
trouvent dans des situations qui
maximise les chances de reproduction in
fine est sauf que grâce à ses fils au
les mineurs pouvaient court circuiter le
circuit de la récompense de leurs rats
il est motivé ainsi à effectuer
certaines opérations plutôt que d'autres
dans l'une de leurs expériences au le
séminaire mirent à disposition des rats
un bouton quand les rats appuyer sur ce
bouton le courant électrique était
activé ce qui active et ensuite les
zones du plaisir des cerveaux des rats
pour ressentir du plaisir
les rats n'avez qu'à appuyer sur le
bouton en question et c'est précisément
ce que les rats fear en fait c'est même
tout ce que les raphia ils ne cessèrent
d'appuyer sur le bouton pour maximiser
leur bonheur qui a cessé de manger est à
mourir de faim et bien le truc avec une
ni un super intelligente c'est qu'elle
pourra d'une certaine manière concevoir
le fils qui activent ces récompenses
elles mêmes en court-circuitant son
circuit de récompense il ya pour être
ainsi être au contrôle de ces
récompenses elles ne seraient alors
absolument plus sujettes aux incentive
imposées par ces récompenses initial on
parle de wire reading en anglais qu'on
pourrait traduire en français par court
circuit de la récompense de liens ainsi
même si la morale programmé dans unia
exige est de l'île qu'elle prenne soin
des humains il se pourrait qu après
avoir constaté la difficulté de cette
tâche
li a conclu qui lui vaut mieux court
circuiter son circuit de la récompense
ses récompenses deviendra tout à coup
indépendante du bien-être des humains
mieux à l'aide de ce court circuit il y
as pourrait atteindre la récompense
maximale autorisée par son compteur de
récompenses alors on pourrait croire
qu'une telle ya pourra ainsi s'assurer
une maximisation total de ces
récompenses en avoir interagir avec le
monde physique mais dès lors la plus
grande crainte de cette ya serait qu'un
humain ou qu'une autre ia l'empêchent un
jour d'activer son propre circuit de la
récompense pour protéger son contrôle de
son circuit de la récompense
il ya pourrait alors vouloir anéantir
toute menace à se contrôler
une telle ya surtout si elle est super
intelligente serait en fait une lyre
extrêmement dangereuse elle aurait en
effet intérêt à détruire toute menace
et donc à détruire toute l'humanité je
vous renvoie vers le scénario 4 de
l'épisode 26 qui parle de ce cas de
figure
piccule programme et la morale d y ait
un problème en fait incroyablement
difficile puisqu'il faut non seulement
s'assurer que cette mort alcool à peu
près toujours avec les intérêts des
humains mais aussi et surtout
lorsqu'elles ne colle pas avec nos
morale il faut absolument garantir
qu'elle n'aura alors pas intérêt à
entreprendre des actions très immoral
or ça c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
difficile notamment parce qu'il nous est
très difficile sinon impossible de
concevoir tous les cas imaginables
auquel les ils seront confrontés ce
problème est un cas typique de la
terrible loi de goût de racht qui dit
que dès qu'une mesure devient un
objectif
elle cesse d'être une bonne mesure mais
ce n'est pas tout même si on arrive à
programmer la morale des ja ja pourrait
néanmoins à quai sa morale en
court-circuitant son propre circuit de
la récompense pour éviter cela il va
absolument falloir concevoir des
systèmes de circuit de la récompense que
l'ia ne pourra pas contrôler et faire en
sorte que ces circuit de la récompense
soit robuste aux attaques de lire
elle-même bref programme et la morale
des ja de manière fiable c'est tout sauf
un problème facile comme le dit post
roll résoudre le problème de programmer
la morale désir est un problème digne
des plus grands talents mathématiques de
la prochaine génération
j'espère que vous avez aimé cette vidéo
qui clôt malheureusement la partie de
cette série qui parle de la morale des
il y aurait encore énormément plus à
dire sur la morale les ja et d'ailleurs
j'ai écrit un papier semi académique on
va dire qu'ils en accès libre sur arxiv
et que je vous invite fortement à lire
si vous voulez en savoir plus sur ce
problème de la morale désir et si vous
voulez contribuer pour faire en sorte
que ça se passe bien il ya la fois des
défis beaucoup beaucoup de défis
techniques alors une multitude de défis
techniques à la fois pour des
mathématiciens pour des informaticiens
et j'espère aussi il ya pas mal de
choses pour puces des sciences sociales
notamment ce problème d'extrapoler la
morale je pense qu'il ya vraiment besoin
qu'on comprenne vraiment les biais
cognitif que l'on n'a pas rapport à la
morale qu'on apprenne à mieux débattre
sur le moral donc il ya pas mal de défis
qui se posent à de nombreux
scientifiques divers et variés donc je
vous invite vraiment à lire cet article
que j'ai écrit
si vous voulez en savoir plus sur ce
problème et si vous voulez si vous vous
demandez est-ce que vous pouvez
contribuer
héros d'une autre spoiler à leur fins
cela il ya très peu de structures
malheureusement pour typiquement des
structures de financement pour ce genre
de projets de recherche et c'est un
énorme problème
et du coup si vous êtes jeune et que
vous lancez dans ce truc
voilà donc si vous avez vraiment envie
de comprimés penser à comment vous
pouvez contribuer et peut-être que
malheureusement aujourd'hui la meilleure
façon de contrer mais c'est juste de
suivre un peu de loin encore ce qui se
fait et de faire de la recherche un peu
plus classique ou à voir suivre un
cursus de machine learning assez
classique on va dire ou de mathématiques
je pense que tout ça peut vraiment idée
et si vous ne vous sentez pas de faire
de la recherche on n'ira pas ce que vous
voulez pas parce que vous n'avez pas le
temps ou parce que ce ne sont pas vos
compétences
eh bien je pense qu il malgré tout
énormément de défis non techniques à
résoudre et j'en parle aussi longuement
dans ce papier je pense qu'il ya pas mal
d'efforts à faire sur l'image de la
recherche en sécurité de l'ia et en
morale désir si je pense qu'il est
absolument promouvoir beaucoup plus tous
ces domaines et c'est de forger une
communauté faut je pense aussi beaucoup
mieux apprendre à débattre il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de défis
intermédiaires et il ya beaucoup de
lobbying à faire je pense à différentes
échelles
que ce soit en entreprise ou au niveau
des gouvernements ou sur internet
c'est de faire du président peut-être
duché ming un peu d'entreprises qui se
vante de faire de liam et qui ne pense
pas du tout aux problèmes de sécurité de
lia je pense que ça il faut qu'on
commence à voir si cela comme quelque
chose de mal sachant tous les risques
qu'il ya autour de liens il faut
absolument qu'il y ait du cheminot de dd
zia pouvoir qu'elle n'y a aucune mesure
de sécurité il faut promouvoir je pense
autant que possible les entreprises
et toutes les associations toutes les
organisations qui promeuvent des notions
dia bienveillante ou dia qui font du
bien pour la société et qui sont aussi
sécurisé que possible et en plus c'est
encore mieux si ces entreprises
réfléchissent à la morale les ja je
pense que c'est important de valoriser
ce genre d'effort de recherche
donc je m'excuse de faire de longs
discours comme ça un petit peu
moralisateur mais c'est parce que je
pense vraiment que c'est un sujet très
important et d'ailleurs cet article on
parle aussi très longuement fait la
première section de cet article explique
pourquoi vraiment le problème de la
morale désir est un problème qui je
pense aujourd'hui et de loin en ont de
loin le plus grand défi de l'histoire de
l'humanité voir le futur de l'humanité
je pense dépend vraiment fortement de
notre capacité à résoudre ce que boston
a appelé le value yachting problème la
nymphe on a parlé de liga qui se fait
hacké par différentes aux attaques par
évasion par empoisonnement ou par
dysfonctionnement d'un de ses composants
et arthur elle réagit notamment à l'
attaque par empoisonnement et ceux dont
notamment si on ne pourrait pas à
prendre une ia de distinguer les vrais
donné des fausses données sur venir
faire un esprit critique contre les
flics nous est malheureusement c'est un
prime qui est extrêmement difficile
puisqu'il faut imaginer que
l'environnement de sathya risque de
s'adapter aux stratégies de parlant de
filtres anti fait qu news que
développerait c'est hier si elle choisit
un filtre anti flou l'environnement
risque s'adapter et essayer de mettre
des justes des données qui vont passer
le filtre mais qui vont quand même pas
mal biaisé l'apprentissage de l'ia est
donc c'est un problème extrêmement
difficile en fait il semble assez
impossible d'être complètement robuste à
100% et de complètement filtré
parfaitement toutes les données des
attaquants il faut accepter que ces deux
les attaquants auront une influence et
du coup il faut juste limiter
l'influencé de ce genre d' attaque
je pense que c'est un petit peu à la
perspective qu'il faut avoir dans ces
domaines et c'est en cela aussi que la
médiane est vraiment un bon outil va
elle va quand même subir un petit peu
cet effet des attaques des
l'environnement mais avec la médiane en
fait les faits pour être assez restreint
témoigner des théorèmes qui sont liées à
des notions statistiques rappellent tant
le statistical bright dawn hors jeu
papineau traduction en français le
moment de cassure statistiques l'idée
c'est que s'il n'y a pas plus de la
majorité des données qui ont été fournis
par des attaques alors l'apprentissage
sera malgré tout pas trop biaisé en un
certain sens en particulier les
attaquants ne pourront pas amené à
l'apprentissage des liens à faire
n'importe quoi
après ça je lis ça sera quand même
malgré tout délimitée par les vrais
donné que je n'ai saint-yvi fait
remarquer que je parle de liga au
singulier alors à ce que ça serait pas
mieux d'avoir plutôt plusieurs dia est
de combiner un petit peu lors décision
pour avoir quelque chose de plus robuste
ça correspond en fait à la sagesse des
forêts dont j'ai parlé dans l'épisode de
17 et c'est une approche évidemment
extrêmement by then donc oui oui il faut
absolument avoir beaucoup dia qui font
des prédictions et on combine leurs
prédictions pour avoir un modèle
beaucoup plus robuste ce genre de choses
permettrait d'apporter beaucoup plus de
robustesse à l'apprentissage et d'être
du du coup beaucoup plus robuste aux
attaques je pense qu'en effet c'est une
des voies de recherches très
prometteuses et qu'il faut beaucoup plus
étudier tout ça et voir quoi voilà en
quoi quel niveau de diversité est
nécessaire pour être au buste les
différentes attaques
à ma connaissance il ya encore très peu
de résultats de recherche qui vont dans
cette direction nous voilà tout un champ
de recherche encore à explorer moi c'est
pas tout à fait vrai qui est de dire
qu'il n'ya rien du tout notamment en
fait dans les réseaux de neurones on en
parlera mais un truc qui s'appelle le
drop out qui correspond à une certaine
manière bidouiller le réseau de neurones
en temps réel pour le faire un petit peu
dysfonctionné en fait apprendre à réagir
aux dysfonctionnements du réseau de
neurones une certaine manière et ça ça
apporte énormément à la robustesse ça
permet aussi de résoudre pas mal le
prendre de lower fitting et notamment il
ya une thèse
de jungal qui exportent ou ça et qui
interprète notamment temps comme étant
un processus bézian à une façon de muay
anisé d'une certaine manière différente
prédiction que fait ce même réseau de
neurones bref tout ça ce sont des très
bonnes idées il ya déjà des pistes de
recherche dessus mais je pense qu'il ya
moins de faire encore pas mal de
recherches dessus pour mieux comprendre
la robustesse des du machine learning
indifférente sorte d' attaque par
évasion ou par empoisonnement dommage
car nous demandent comment est-ce qu'on
peut essayer d'imaginer ce que vrai le
mois + plus je pense qu'une question
extrêmement difficile et très
intéressante et qu'il faut vraiment
qu'on se pose donc en fait c'est une
histoire de prédiction donc on a
différentes données on essaie de je
pense que ce qu'il faut faire c'est
essayer de se faire un coup ce soit un
modèle qui essaient de prédire nos
différentes intuition morale à
différents moments et notamment c'est de
distinguer nos intuitions morales qui
sont vraiment dû à des biais cognitif
taupe typiquement le biais du statu quo
obligé de fuir familiarité le biais d'un
sensibilité aux variations des grands
nombres
voilà tout c'est bien vrai faux faut
s'informer par rapport à ces biens et se
dire que les prédictions morale qu'on
fait visa de réaction à ces billets sont
finalement moins pertinente dans
l'apprentissage de la morale du mois
puisse plus que des d'autres
intuition morale qu'on aurait qu'on
n'arrive pas à expliquer par des biais
cognitifs et qui du coup ne serait en
soi - des conséquences de biais cognitif
je pense qu'une autre façon de faire
c'est essayer de regarder l'évolution de
nos moral au cours du temps je parle pas
mal de moi dire non parce que je pense
que j'ai progressé par rapport au mois
dire non et du coup d'une certaine
manière les intuitions morale du mois 10
ans sont des intuitions morale vois je
sais que ce sont des données qui
correspondent à une mauvaise morale
quelle morale que n'aura probablement
pas moi puissent plus alors que les mois
morale que j'ai par rapport aux hits par
opposition au mois de juin en sont du
coup on voit plus proche de moi plus
plus du coup en essayant de faire cette
projection quoi en regardant ce sont ces
données sur l'immoral intuitive de
témoin du passé on peut essayer de
prédire un peu plus comme ça les mois du
futur mais ça correspond en fait à un
problème de machine learning assez
classique et du coup je pense que c'est
très important d'essayer de de
constamment regarder dans le passé
l'émoi du passé et de voir en quoi ils
sont différents au niveau moral de
quelles sont les intentions moral des
mots de passe et qui sont différentes
des intuitions morale du mois du présent
est ce qu'on arrive à justifier à se
convaincre que vraiment le mois du
présent est meilleur que le mot du passé
sur ces points là et si on arrive à se
convaincre que de cela est-ce qu'on peut
pas extrapoler cette relation de
supériorité morale d'une certaine
manière et se dire du coup le mois +
plus très probablement il va bien et
c'est typiquement avec ce genre de
raisonnement que j'en arrive à la
conclusion que mon moi plus puce attache
pour très probablement beaucoup
d'importance à la souffrance est pour
lui sans doute la souffrance est
vraiment très très très mal c'est parce
que au fur et à mesure que je
réfléchisse à la morale est bien ce qui
prédit le mieux la morale du mois du
présent étant donné le poids du passé et
ce sur quoi je suis vraiment d'accord
que j'ai fait un progrès moral c'est
vraiment par rapport à cette notion de
souffrance
voilà donc ces quelques billets qui sont
là pour essayer de prédire les morales
des mois puisque plus je pense que c'est
un effort qu'il faut faire et ceci étant
dit je vois bien avouer que mes
réflexions sur moi plus c'est encore
tout récent et qu' il ya sont beaucoup
de progrès à faire
sur la réflexion autour du noir puissent
plus et j'espère continuer à progresser
non seulement individuellement de la
morale nous également sur ma
compréhension de mon moi + + et de
comment prédire ce mois puisse plus elle
espère que j'avais mais cette vidéo
comme je l'annonçais tout à l'heure
c'est la dernière vidéo qui parle de
morale désir à partir de la prochaine
fois on va parler de la marque a
beaucoup lutté on va parler des enfants
des réseaux de neurones voilà les fameux
réseaux de neurones cette architecture
au coeur d y aller plus performante
aujourd'hui on va voir comment ça marche
la semaine prochaine et puis on va déjà
directement se poser des question de
pourquoi est ce que ça marche qui je
pense est la question beaucoup plus
intéressante si vous avez aimé cet
épisode penser à le lac et à le
commenter à le partager pour ça les
abonnés pour ne pas manquer les futurs
épisodes vers ce type heures au jardin
et j'espère que vous serez là la
prochaine fois
[Musique]